I haven't done this all I don't know hey
alright alright Here I am Here I am
are you ready so I called a lift and
we're not really going anywhere we're
just using a car I'm gonna help you my
line is uh hey can I help you um can I
help you I'm gonna help you I'm gonna
help you I'm gonna help you no we don't
need tractors
I mean I mainly did day of rehearsal
everyone address oh it's the making
frame for some reason if you'd pick the
mic isn't frame let's just cut for a
second
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
actually Amanda Amanda Amanda
[Music]
oh boy what up sweet thing hello how are
you good yeah I'm gonna cut right to the
chase okay because I live in the roar of
that [ __ ] motorcycle and I want to
take I'm sorry about this VIN bro it's
great that's money fast woman
[Music]
listen I'm gonna cut right you're not
leaving yet little things in here
these the constant weird things in here
these wine glasses can you see them
goddamn close up I just carried step
four very or so
[Music]